hallo deutsch schule top 100 substantive
hören und sprechen die pizza die pizza
das haus das haus das handy das handy
der mann der mann die frau die frau das
buch das buch die brille die brille das
radio das radio das fahrrad das fahrrad
die hose
die hose der rucksack der rucksack der
hund der hund die katze die katze die
sonne die sonne das
geld das geld das taxi das taxi das
flugzeug das flugzeug das schiff das
schiff der vogel der vogel das klavier
das klavier die gitarre die gitarre
spielst du auch ein instrument der apfel
der apfel die banane die banane der baum
der baum der hammer der hammer
der fernseher der fernseher die toilette
die toilette das toilettenpapier das
toilettenpapier das waschbecken das
waschbecken die avocado die avocado die
paprika
die paprika die möhre die möhre die
ananas die ananas der käse der käse das
eis das eis die zitrone die zitrone die
polizei die polizei die feuerwehr die
feuerwehr
der krankenwagen der krankenwagen
der brief der brief das portemonnaie das
portemonnaie der lippenstift der
lippenstift die armbanduhr die
armbanduhr die krawatte die krawatte
das kleid das kleid die handschuhe die
handschuhe der hut der hut der
kleiderbügel
der kleiderbügel die batterie die
batterie der kopfhörer
der kopfhörer welche musik findest du
gut
der bus der bus der zug der zug das
motorrad das motorrad der roller der
rolle der fußball der fußball der
notausgang der notausgang der
geldautomat der geldautomat die
kreditkarte die kreditkarte der ring der
ring die schuhe die schuhe der spiegel
der spiegel
der stern der stern der kürbis der
kürbis der kinderwagen der kinderwagen
der arzt
der arzt der lehrer der lehrer der fisch
der fisch die biene
die biene der schlüssel der schlüssel
der kaffee der kaffee die ampel die
ampel welche farben hat die ampel die
straße die straße
der zebrastreifen der zebrastreifen der
blumenstrauß
der blumenstrauß
das brot das brot das fenster das
fenster das geschenk das geschenk das
pferd das pferd der schneemann der
schneemann die uhr
die uhr
der tisch der tisch der stuhl der stuhl
das messer das messer die gabe die gabe
der löffel der löffel
der teller der teller die tasse die
tasse das glas das glas das bier das
bier der regenschirm der regenschirm der
personalausweis der personalausweis der
reisepass der reisepass die kerze die
kerze die lampe die lampe das sofa das
sofa das bügelbrett das bügelbrett das
bügeleisen das bügeleisen der mix sei
der mix sei der einkaufswagen der
einkaufswagen die waschmaschine die
waschmaschine super das waren die top
100 substantive abonniere unseren kanal
und aktivieren das kleine glöckchen gib
uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben
und in dieser playlist findest du
weitere videos zum deutsch lernen
klicke jetzt auf diese playlist